well it's it was 20 years ago June the
1st 1984 maybe 19 years ago Steve
Wolfram was 25 years old he got on to an
airplane in New York City to fly the
London the plane took off somewhere over
the Atlantic
Steve pulls out a sheaf of papers and if
you were sitting next to him on that
flight you would have thought well this
is not a particularly normal person
because the papers were a printout from
his computer and they look kind of like
a crossword puzzle they were there was
rows and rows and rows and rows of boxes
some of them were black some of them
were white there was one black box on
the top line and if you went down each
row it would be more black boxes here
and black boxes there white boxes here
about boxes there and as you kept
turning the pages they would form
patterns and then the patterns would go
away so imagine sitting next to a guy in
a plane who's staring intently at black
boxes and white boxes and turning the
page and whenever it gets really weird
is as you look on down in this in this
pattern the patterns disappear and the
crossword puzzle kind of goes berserk
and you get this crazy quilt pattern
'less chaotic jumble of black & white
boxes and so now you got this guy
staring it pretty much just nothing like
a mess a riot
chaos on a page and the odd thing is he
seems to be loving it
I mean he's over the moon with
excitement it's like he's been hit with
a thunderbolt and he later tells the
London Daily Telegraph that that print
out and we will hope to show you it
tonight who is the most important thing
I've ever seen in science he just had a
profound insight in his intellectual
life or so far anyway it led to this
enormous book where it says on the very
first page what I had seen was the
beginning of a crack in the very
foundations of existing science and the
first clue to a whole new kind of
science which is of course the title of
the book a new kind of science so
tonight we're gonna figure out or try to
figure out what it was that Stephen saw
so you can decide if what made him gasp
will make you gasp let's welcome Stephen
butcher
so actually let's just start out with
where are you from where am i from I'm
from England originally we're bounced I
was born in London nah you were didn't
grow up in Oxford I grew up in Oxford oh
and your dad was a was a man novelist
yes and business person yes what kind of
business and very what I considered to
be a very low tech business things do
with textiles fix us the garment
business maybe no no okay
your mom was a philosophy professor Oh
at Oxford oh okay
and finally I read her books not not it
took me a very long time it took me
probably 20 years to actually get around
to finally deciding that I could read
those books it's because they're very
fat or because they're your mom's books
and you just read because when I was a
kid I said if there's one thing I'll
never do when I'm grown up it's to be a
philosopher hey let me ask you some cute
you've got to eatin ya ask you some cure
false questions about eating is it true
that you sold your Eton uniform that
black thing that the kids were there to
an American set of American tourists who
thought it adorable and wanted to have
it that was a long time ago but yes I
think that's true remember how much for
oh but no I certainly do not
it was a very it was was one of my less
interesting business transactions
is it true that when playing cricket or
soccer you would calculate we're on the
field you're at least likely to get the
ball and that is where you chose to
stand yes that's that's true that's true
that's true is it true that while you
like your computers and there's a young
age your first true real love was
chocolate and you had according to one
Oxford physicist a million chocolate
bars a day so if chocolate causes
anything he says Wolfram's gonna get it
probably so yes when did you get any
computers I got interested in computers
around 1972 1973
I was actually firstly the end but 12th
on working there I was actually
interested in physics and I actually had
a specific physics problem that I wanted
to solve with computers and that was
sort of what got me started and really
learning lots about computers okay
are you a chess player no I'm a lousy
well I I've played it I'm lousy at it
really so when you first played you lost
or no i when i first played when i was
about seven i won for a few games and
then I started losing and then I stopped
playing
let me just gallop through your early
life here just stop me what I'll ask you
at 14 you write a physics paper that was
accepted actually by a prestigious
physical professional journal and yet
you leave eaten without actually
graduating why didn't you graduate from
what we would call high school oh the
system in England is different I I got
in England at that time if you got a
scholarship to Oxford or Cambridge you
didn't do the standard things called a
levels which are the kind of government
kind of things and I got a scholarship
to Oxford so I didn't need to do that
you knew so so 17 you go to Oxford you
read physics you published a few more
papers you leave Oxford without
graduating why'd you do that because I
was going to go to graduate school
because I figured why spend another two
years in college if you can be going to
graduate school but you have to get get
a piece of paper to get to move to the
next stage or they just move you right
now well I think if you've published a
few papers that those countless pieces
of paper okay so you leave Oxford you go
to the Argonne National Laboratory in
Illinois then you get invited to Caltech
and that curiosity is going from Oxford
to Caltech is that like a kick in the
head and that hard to do
culturally I you know in in the world of
science I think it's a very
internationalized culture you know you
go to a physics seminar in Oxford you go
to a physics seminar in Caltech the only
difference is there there are a few
differences in clothing that you'll
notice but that's about it
well you didn't like notice surfer
culture or valley culture or anything
while you were telling I think Pasadena
is fairly far in from
the woods all right so Caltech you
arrived at 18 you earn a PhD you know
I'm the web 1979 you're 20 years old
now you're a PhD so you go to Princeton
you leave Princeton University Illinois
then we can professor of math physics
computer science you leave diversity of
Illinois you're the youngest recipient
of a MacArthur Foundation Genius award
and then you create a product called
Mathematica what is Mathematica I mean
many people here probably use it but for
those who don't know so it's it's a
general environment for doing technical
computing a form wants to calculate
something it's the thing to use to do
that and it's it's it's something it's
sort of based on this a language that I
developed that's sort of took a bunch of
thinking to figure out how do you take
all these kind of disparate operations
that one wants to do in calculating
things for science for engineering for
financial analysis whatever else and how
does one kind of make a a uniform
structure to put all these things into
and that that's sort of the foundation
of what Mathematica is it's now used by
a few million people around the world
for a wide diversity of things many many
more than I could ever have imagined
when those Helene Curtis uses it to get
perfectly consistency in shampoo stuff
but possibile you know it's fourteen
hundred and ninety five bucks a pop
there abouts and yet you have like one
or two million customers this means that
you probably are rich enough at this
point once you look at the company gets
going to do what you please so I call
your attention to this apparently what
you do is just quit academia you say I'm
quoting for something I found many years
ago you stoled somebody right now I
could be leading what many people would
consider a very happy life flying around
from unconference to another giving
talks publishing a paper every six
months but I don't want to live that way
it's as boring as helll would you
describe yourself as a person who gets
bored easily mm-hmm I'm not sure about
that because you know if you look at
what I actually spend my time doing I do
very large projects
I mean Mathematica has been a big
project my book has been a 10-year
project I'm not sure that a person who
does ten-year projects could seriously
be said to be somebody who gets bored
that is
all right so you decide to write a book
actually it turns out to be this book
which is twelve hundred and sixty three
pages long
five hundred eighty three thousand three
hundred thirteen words three hundred and
forty eight pages of notes is a very
very big book yes and the end famously
you've just you've actually counted the
number of keystrokes that it took you to
yes you have the number in your head one
hundred million keystrokes roughly and
just moving the mouse along the surface
of your desk for however many years it
was how many Mouse miles did you travel
I think the answer is about a hundred
mouse miles how long did you when you
started it how long did you think it
would take to write I thought it would
take a couple of years and the reason
that I was so far wrong was basically I
discovered a lot more than I expected to
discover I mean I had seen a number of
phenomena in the 1980s that I thought
were really interesting and I kind of
hadn't realized just how important and
kind of deep those phenomena would turn
out to be and I I kind of started
looking at all these different areas
physics biology mathematics and so on
and sort of kept on opening each area up
and trying to see whether things I
discovered would be relevant to those
areas
I had thought they wouldn't be
particularly relevant and I suddenly
discovered yes they're very relevant and
they have things to say that are very
different from what the foundations of
those fields have been in the past and
so on we didn't this worry you that if
you stayed curious you'd never get out
there's a giant sucking sound of the
book you know yes well the only thing
that that gave me sort of some some kind
of solid ground was that I had a
definite table of contents for the book
and that didn't change for about eight
years
oh I see so one of the sections was
called fundamental physics for example
so they were there it was not a it was
not an unambitious table of contents but
it was one that didn't start getting
extra major pieces because I kind of
knew what the outline of areas you do it
in order did you go from chapter 1 to
chapter 2 teacher not completely no well
so you could have died in there you
could still be doing it actually yes so
that's just because the by the way how
long did it take how many years it took
ten and a half years and now your work
habits during this period have become
somewhat legendary if not peculiar can
you do
scribe because your friend Terry
Sejnowski says he totally dropped out of
the scene in every sense of the word so
like on a typical day six years ago when
did you rise Oh probably 2:00 in the
afternoon perhaps and then what did you
do then I played CEO for a number of
hours running my company and Mathematica
yes did you go to the office or did you
stay at no I was a remote CEO so this
was phone or teleconferencing or
something or email email those sorts of
things
okay so the hour is 20 I guess you've
done your two hours it's now five
o'clock or something now what well
actually the the company running thing
tended to take a few more hours than
that okay it's some it's it's not even
with the most terrific people and a
company one still has to actually do
real work to make it all happen but
after you know dinner and other kinds of
things eventually later in the evening I
could really get sort of undivided work
and then sit down and start working on
whatever was the next thing that I want
to sit on upstairs to this sort of wood
lined attic or something yes you're
shutting the door yes and how late do
you work Oh usually until 6:00 in the
morning or 7:00 in the morning or
something like that did you take days
off no I didn't actually for nine years
we all pretty much did you take
vacations no I managed to finally take a
vacation after I finished the book is it
true by the way that on those occasions
when you do take vacations you go to the
airport and look at the place at the top
the destination of the first airplane
leaving and just get on it
or that that was from long ago yes I did
that long ago dude okay so is it also
true that gene buck one of your
marketing execs when they told you that
she's gonna be busy on Superbowl Sunday
and you said to her what's that hmm I
could have done it I think I know yes
all right so you lose a little bit of
year here but you do get married you get
three children in them in the mix and
now before we discuss what's in the book
which we're gonna do at first I want to
ask you why
why do a book wing why not if you had
something in your mind why not do what
Albert Einstein did and just you know
publish whatever it was you wanted to
say in scholarly journals assessed by
referees read by scholars why did you
choose to do it this other way
relativity is a simpler concept to
explain in 10 pages than what I'm trying
to talk about that's your answer I mean
you're no bigger revolute you have a
bigger revolution in your head or
something just more complex to describe
it's it's it's it's a bigger
intellectual framework I mean the the
the kind of model of publishing papers
and you know 10 20 page paper whatever
this is a terrific model when one's
dealing with kind of the normal progress
of science of kind of incremental sorts
of things happening the thing that I
tried to do for the last 20 years is to
develop sort of a much larger
intellectual framework and I I certainly
tried the scheme of publishing papers
about what I was doing did that in the
early 1980s they were they were pretty
successful I mean you can kind of go
back and look there's a kind of big
literature tree that grew from the
papers that I wrote but what mostly grew
was detailed technical work done on the
basis of those papers not things that
kind of really captured that the larger
intellectual framework that that I
thought those papers kind of were
beginning to glimpse so so I kind of
decided it kind of had the question how
does one communicate a kind of large
intellectual framework I don't think
it's particularly easy the best scheme
that I came up with was try and write a
single book that kind of has the whole
story kind of packaged as well as I
could and sort of presented all at once
you were trying to avoid having a thing
chopped up into little particular bits
you said here's the whole cake and you
wanted to look like a cake like the
whole why write a popular science book I
mean this is written in ordinary English
that pretty much anybody you can look at
the pictures if you get bored you know
the captions that you get scared you can
then go back and read the pros and the
pros isn't that I mean the length is a
killer but the read is actually quite
right well so I mean you know this is a
field the things that I'm trying to
describe there aren't sort of experts in
the things I'm trying to describe
because it's sort of a new framework I
mean there are experts in the specific
areas that I try to address and but if I
had tried to sort of write a book that
kind of spoke to each of those experts I
would have ended up with a book whose
audience was was basically nobody so you
want this audience well one of the
things that I found is that what what I
tend to believe is that if I really
understand an idea clearly enough it
should be possible to explain it without
a lot of kind of technical
superstructure and that's what I that's
what I set myself the task of doing when
I wrote the book was to try and take the
ideas that I had and and kind of
polished them to the point where I could
really explain them in kind of plain
language and pictures and so on without
having to bring in lots of technical
formalism and you have a model I mean
Leonardo published his dialogues and
regular Italian so that everybody could
understand them and and Darwin wrote for
the you you have a model in your head
someone you were aping copy well it's
it's I mean I certainly I'm aware of I'm
quite a student of the history of
science and I've kind of I I kind of
have this idea that you know history
tends to repeat itself so it's worth
knowing what happened when people did
things particular ways last time around
so to speak and it certainly you know
I've certainly looked at you know what
Darwin did with Origin of Species for
example and the things that sort of have
worked well over the course of time and
I checked that Darwin to the original
run print run of Origin of Species was
twelve hundred and fifty copies sold out
the first day
yes how'd you do mind sold out the first
day to like you had fifty thousand
copies
yes sorry I don't know you can actually
count you don't adjust for inflation on
books
you just beat Darwin I guess in that
small and not very variable all right
let me address now the problem that
you're trying to solve here if I went to
the top of the Tower of Pisa and I
dropped an iron ball down off the side
of a Tower of Pisa classical
mathematicians could predict many things
about my dropping balling know
when everywhere was winning with
Landsman or if I was looking for the
patterns of Mars and I wanted to know
where Mars would show up in a week
I could probably plot and figure out so
math has worked for a long time but if I
miss this glass and we have a sudden
splash what a mathematician be able to
describe the essence of what just
happened the water hitting the floor and
sprinting out and all this way not very
well I mean this is what's tended to
happen is that the sort of mathematical
approach to science which has been kind
of the dominant one for the last 300
years or so it's worked very well when
the kind of phenomena that are being
described are for example visually
simple planets going around in roughly
elliptical orbits things like that fluid
flow where the sort of smooth patterns
of flow and so on when things get more
complicated
in physics also in areas like biology
there hasn't been so much success there
hasn't really been a good understanding
developed of how complicated things come
to be the way they are in nature are
there so many complicated things in
nature that if you were a painter of
nature and wanted to understand why it
looks the way it does and what it's
under structure is would current
mathematics traditional mathematics be
able to describe much of what we see or
very little of what we see depends on
what you concentrate on I mean for
example in technology and engineering
one tends to concentrate when one does
Engineering one's interested in building
systems where one can foresee what
they're going to do and make sure that
they do what one intends them today um
so if one's doing engineering and one
looks at nature one tends to one will
tend to concentrate on those things
which can successfully be dealt with by
traditional mathematics that have very
innocent simple predictable behavior
right if one's interested in for example
showing the beauties of nature in
painting and photography on something
like that one might very well
concentrate on those aspects of nature
for which it would be very difficult to
have kind of traditional mathematical
explanations flouds
for example puffs of cigar smoke
twirling in the air yes waterfalls
so if very complex sort of semi chaotic
behavior is indescribable mathematically
and certain these are describable then
you for some reason felt lonely or you
wanted for some reason to complete the
picture of the universe you wanted to be
able to say I can describe these things
that are presently undescribable
and so if equations the typical way of
doing this wasn't quite working what do
you propose as a better way to describe
the universe well so one of the things
to realize is if one is going to be able
to do theoretical science it better be
the case that nature follows some kind
of definite laws some kind of definite
underlying rules the question is what
should be the kind of the primitives the
the elements that go into the making up
those rules and what's been kind of the
the traditional idea in physics says
those primitives should be the things
the kinds of things that we've invented
in human mathematics things like numbers
Exponential's derivatives integrals
things of that kind the question is is
that the most general kind of thing that
one can have indefinite rules or can
there be more general kinds of
primitives that can go into having
definite rules and the thing that that I
realized now 20 years ago is there are
more general kinds of things that one
can put into definite rules and those
more general kinds of things are the
kinds of things that one can have in
computer programs in computer programs
this is a little hard I think for people
because you just when you look around at
your shoe or at a cloud you don't think
of that as having to do with a computer
exactly let's get into that a minute
what is an and also before I get there
I'm just interested in the hunger in you
you were trying to you you were worried
that there's an awful lot that we see
around us that just eludes our
understanding that we can't quite grasp
and you thought I'd like to be able to
understand it describe it yes I mean I
was I happened to get a and involved in
that particularly by thinking about
cosmology I was interests
in the question of sort of how the
structures emerge in the universe things
like galaxies he saw and this was 20
years ago
much has been discovered about what
happens in cosmology since then but but
at the time sort of one of the key
questions was how does the universe go
from this kind of Big Bang that sort of
a uniform amorphous blob to something
that has all the kinds of structure that
we see what I realized was that that
question sort of how does structure how
do other things complicated things get
made in nature was a much more general
question than just being something that
happen in cosmology it was something
that sort of cut across that was
actually the the core question in a lot
of areas of science that the thing that
a lot of areas of science were running
into and not being able to make progress
because they couldn't have things to say
about that and so I kind of realized if
I could solve that one problem there
would be the potential to really make
progress across lots of different areas
of science so that meant it's worth
spending a lot of effort on that one
problem because if you can crack that
you can get make a lot of progress in a
lot of places
well what tell me what what an algorithm
is so that's a more complicated question
than you might think okay what no you
see you see the thing is that when an
algorithm is a rule for doing things
that's one kind of definition when you
say algorithm you often mean something
like a computer program that a person
would write for a particular purpose I
mean when we think about computer
programs we're used to software that's
made to achieve some particular purpose
that we want
and typically the programs that we work
with a long complicated programs you
know ten thousand hundreds of millions
of lines of code and so on um the thing
that is also an example of a program is
something very tiny some some very
simple rule that just says if you have
this arrangement of black squares then
you'll get a white square on the next
step those sorts of things those are not
the kinds of things that we normally
think of as or that we often think of as
algorithms because algorithms are
typically kind of designed for a purpose
mm-hm what the thing that I kind of
realized was an important thing to look
at
programs that are just definitions of
simple rules not set up for any purpose
that we necessarily know in advance okay
but let's just for the fun of it imagine
that the that nature might represent the
output of a computer just for the fun of
it
then algorithms are rules for computers
would be the rules for nature if that is
true
so that's just to follow that along if
we're going to pretend that everything
around us is the output of a computer
which we'll get back to then everything
has to be looked at a little differently
so that for example time right now I
guess most of us think the time sort of
flows and I think in if a computer is
creating the universe then time would
have to tick tick tick tick
I met us sitting here and would be a new
iteration every instant of the universe
but very discretely mm-hmm what about
space space instead of being this sort
of natural leave but would well so I
mean that this I happen to have a
definite view about what how space and
time might work and that's sort of the
idea that programs are important as sort
of rules underlying what happens in
nature there's some distance between
that idea and the particular ideas that
I happen to have about how space and
time might work so you want one of the
things that that so one of one of the
important worry there's things I'm kind
of yeah there might be a truck coming
through just ignore it though okay so um
so the first thing to understand is sort
of to get an intuition for what these
simple programs that we started to talk
about what they actually do because
without that intuition it's hard to kind
of see how things might work and in the
whole universe
so maybe maybe we should talk a little
bit about about kind of how when one has
a very simple program a program that one
just sort of let's say creates at random
what is it that it will typically do
yeah that's kind of but that's kind of a
basic question now what we might think
is if one has a simple enough program
then inevitably what it will do must be
correspondingly simple right
because it's our kind of experience that
to make something complicated must take
a lot of effort right and that's that
that's what we used to from for example
doing engineering things like that right
so one of the things that that I
discovered that was to me extremely
surprising was that sort of in the world
of programs that intuition is not
correct right if you just kind of look
out there in the world of programs that
what what simple programs typically do
you find that even programs that have
very simple rules can do very
complicated things and I can show maybe
show an example okay so here's a one of
my all-time favorite kinds of programs
this is a thing called the I hope No
okay this so this is a thing called a
cellular automaton and the way it works
is you start off at the top with a row
of black and white cells and then in a
series of steps going down the page you
decide whether each cell would black or
white by using some some definite rule
that depends on the the color of the
cell immediately above a particular cell
and to its left and right so you can
kind of summarize the rule that was used
there by that little icon at the bottom
of that picture well in this particular
case having the simple rules at the
bottom starting from a single black cell
at the top you get a simple uniform
pattern and this just happens like you
don't know what when you press go right
so you just it just each line fills in
and there it is
just and these are the result of those
rules at the bottom exactly okay so the
question then is okay what if we change
the rules what will happen oh okay
that's a different rule it's a different
rule different pattern but it's a simple
rule and we got out a simple pattern
yeah and we might have the guess based
on our kind of everyday experience an
intuition that if the rule is simple the
pattern will always be correspondingly
simple just like in music chopstick
sounds like a simple bit of business a
Beethoven symphony sounds like you've
done a lot of work yes so the question
is does one really have to do a lot of
work to make something complicated
happen so let's try a different rule
here let's that some there's another
rule saying
different detailed these rules at the
bottom ER if you'd do this here then you
have to do that there if it's three on
one side and you make it white and just
simple little yes okay that's right so
it's like if you were to write that as a
computer program it would be just a few
lines one or two lines of computer code
to describe I mean I don't we're doing
those nine years of you up in the attic
were you just sitting there thinking
well let's just try this one and then
you'd see what happens let's try this
window you see but that was probably of
those nine years probably four of them
was spent during that day
the others were spent analyzing what
happened when one did that one again so
you can see in this case you're starting
to get a more more complicated pattern
that particular one um see the if you
continue that one for a while you get
this very intricate pattern so but you
see this nesting sort of thing where
little guys would nest inside big guys
and a lot right that's a pretty common
thing either you see things repeat or
you see things nesting inside each other
so this this is a case where simple rule
intricate pattern but still ultimately
very regular nested pattern right and
back early 1980s I certainly thought
that this was as complicated as you
could get from rules as simple as these
right well I think you mentioned at the
beginning now you'll get on the plane
today right well in particular I I kind
of decided you know I better just check
what happens with all possible rules of
this kind do kind of a systematic
experiment and you can kind of number
these rules and this one is rule number
30 and there's what happens when you
when you run rule number 30 you start
off from one black square at the top and
then you let the thing evolve and after
a while you get a pattern that looks
like this and what's remarkable about
this pattern is all you put in is that
simple rule down at the bottom and the
statement we're going to start from one
black square at the top and what you get
out is all of this complicated stuff now
the thing about this mean it looks very
complicated has by the way some sort of
a left something's going on on the left
that's different from what's going on
rather right that's correct
why's that
it happens to be a rule that isn't
symmetrical left to right there so
there's some regularity on the left but
for example if you look at the center
column of cells for all practical
purposes it seems perfectly random now
you get thrilled by this you're looking
at this on the plane and you're thinking
there's no logic here no pattern that I
can divine not only do you think that
but you then turn to one of the most
famous scientists in the world dick
Feynman and you say here Richard
look at this and find some kind of order
well didn't quite happen that what
really happened was I was showing him
this and he said you can't possibly be
right that there's no regularity in this
he said I can break any code that you
can set up with with a system like this
so the tool you get on the floor and
he's got these measuring sticks and he
starts looking for something that
repeats there's something that could be
that kind of thing yes and so so what
happens confinement find any any order
here it comes back a while later and he
says no he hasn't found in a thing and
then he said actually it was one of the
nicest compliments I think ever I got
paid Lucy he said to me you know I just
want to ask you one thing I want to ask
you did you know that this particular
rule is going to do all this complicated
stuff I said no you know I I just
systematically looked through all of
these different rules and found this
particular one that did this so he said
I feel a lot better because I thought
you know I was worried you were kind of
smart enough to be able to work out this
is what would happen now they are good
some people in the room who are looking
at this and thinking who cares I mean
what's the difference that so there's a
chaos in the middle what you started
with a simple rule and you generated
nothing in particular why is that so
exciting so if you look at nature
there's a lot of complicated stuff in
nature one of the things that's sort of
in a sense an embarrassment for us right
now is if if you're showing two objects
and you're asked to guess which one is
the artifact which one is the natural
system a pretty good heuristic is to say
the one that looks more complicated is
the one that's the natural system it
seems like Nature has some kind of
secret that allows it to make
complicated stuff in some way that that
we haven't an engineering been able to
emulate the reason I think this is
exciting is because I think this is the
secret that nature is using to make
complicated stuff it's that even very
simple programs if you kind of let them
run loose can make very complicated
things so you're looking at this and
you're thinking in the back of your mind
the splash of water which is so complex
when it hits the floor and splays out
like that probably is if the world is
coming out of a computer is probably
obeying not just a rule not even a
complicated rule but maybe a very simple
rule yes so that all the variety and all
the craziness of the world might be
reducible to a few simple rules and
that's what this tells but that's why I
think this is interesting and important
yes now in addition to that you then
find out that not only do you get
unpredictability but sometimes out of
these clothes come shapes that you've
seen before do you have any of those by
the way oh sure yes so this is again
from same simple rules
let's see look like you know like in
winter time for example when certain
things fall from the sky would be one
impossible right so here's the thing
that can happen so if you're interested
in for example how crystals get made and
how for example complicated-looking
crystals like snowflakes get made you
can make a similarly simple rule that
says you know we have a grid of squares
and each square might be either solid or
not solid and what kinds of rules might
we use to to grow something according to
those rules so they here's an example of
applying a very simple rule of making
something that doesn't look like a
snowflake well having even a tiny bit
more complicated rule and trying to sort
of capture the the physics of what
happens in a growing ice crystal that's
what you get if you look at all the
stages here they are and you can see
that from even from the very simple
rules
applause for snow even from the rules
that made these are incredibly simple
yet the patterns that you get out seem
to sort of capture the essential
features of the complexity that one sees
in snowflakes and it's always a kind of
an important test for a model can you
get a lot out having put only a small
amount in and this is a case where you
can get sort of a lot of complexity out
even though you put on a very simple
model in so you've got snowflakes you
got marking or any other things to show
us there just sure I've got lots of
things the Harris says c-shell branching
leaf pine cones swirling patterns cloud
turbulent streams of water how about
that that's a that this is this is the
beginning of a leaf pattern one of the
things that and by the way this was this
intentional you were you trying to
create a leaf or the belief emerge from
one of these simple rules no I was I was
trying to create a little basically the
the the kind of mode of operation is
given some some phenomenon in nature see
where the one recognizes some particular
kind of simple rule that might be the
origin of that particular phenomenon in
nature it's sort of the same approach
but it's taken in any other kind of way
of doing modeling you kind of have a
certain inventory of model of basic
abstract phenomena that you know about
and you try and match those with the
actual phenomena that you see in nature
so another example would be you're
getting down there at the second to the
last line you're getting very tree like
objects yeah many of these are shapes
that first line up there right that
correspond to shapes of different kinds
of leaves one of the things that that's
interesting in in the biological systems
is the question of when we see
complexity in biology what's the sort of
fundamental origin of that complexity
and kind of with the intuition that to
make something complicated one has to go
to lots of effort people tend to think
okay so where does that effort go in
biology well it must be that there's
some long and circuitous route of
biological evolution and natural
selection that's kind of carefully craft
in the particular forms that we see we
all think
we all think that you know the reason
that zebra has stripes is because that's
good camouflage in the savanna and
millions and millions and millions of
years have taken have basically
preferred that particular set of stripes
although each individual zebra seems to
have its own stripes right but so so one
question is when one sees complicated
pigmentation patterns
I haven't happened to study zebras in
particular so much I've studied mollusks
more than I thought mullets we all know
I'm Alvin su and one can ask the
question so there are here are some some
examples of some mollusks some of which
have pretty complicated patterns on
their shells and the question is how did
that complexity get produced and what I
think is going on is the reason that
it's possible for these mollusks and
make this complexity they do it very
easily and they do it by just
essentially running simple programs and
I like this one so if you look at the
mollusk in the lower in the bottom line
there the the the pattern that's down
below is a pattern that you generated no
that's the photograph of the show but so
the way these shells work they kind of
grow out I think I have an example here
that the shell kind of grows with the
sort of lip of shell it gets added to
progressively by the by the organism
laying it down and as the organism lays
down each successive line of shell it
puts down sort of a pigmentation pattern
on that new line and the question is
what are the rules that govern those
pigment producing cells on the sort of
growing lip of the organism and the
answer I think is that there are simple
rules like these so-called cellular
automata that I showed earlier and one
of the things that sort of curious is
one can ask the question if one looks at
sort of the mollusks of the earth how do
they pick which rules they should use
and one of the strange things is that
that there's great diversity in the
patterns that one season in different
kinds of mollusks but that diversity
seems to correspond rather accurately to
exactly the diversity that one sees
woman looks at sort of all possible
cellular automaton programs so it's as
if the mollusks of the earth are just
sort of picking solar automaton programs
your program says there six ways mollusk
can go and you look around in the real
world and you find that there are six
patterns that mollusks have that that's
more or less the kind of thing here's
the little danger moment here you look
at a surface like that and said wow this
is really like a mollusk
looks like a mollusk show mm-hmm then
you decide I'm not quite sure why but
then you decide you know what maybe real
mollusks are the fruit of some kind of
computer program as well my computer
program produced a mollusk like surface
so maybe real mollusks are also the end
product of a computer that is you have
to think carefully about that okay
because what that's getting out is the
essence of what it means to make a model
of something what does one mean by
making a model of some natural
phenomenon what one means is one's going
to pick certain features of the natural
phenomenon and one's going to be able to
find an abstract explanation of why
those features are the way they are and
one's going to then say there are other
features of this natural phenomena that
we're going to idealize the way that
we're going to ignore that we're going
to kind of not take account of another
it seems to me you're gonna ignore a lot
we're going to ignore the animal inside
the shell you're gonna ignore the
tissues inside the animal you're gonna
ignore the cells inside the tissues you
can ignore an awful lot of stuff and
concentrate on the outside well and go
wah wah the computer equals the real
thing but but but okay so so any kind of
time where you're doing modeling you
have that issue thank you the it's let's
say one's looking at a much more
traditional kind of thing once one's
looking at let's say you know the earth
going around the Sun um in some let's
say roughly elliptical orbit so there
will always be features of what happens
when the earth goes around the Sun that
one's Newtonian model will not capture
mm-hmm whether it's some detail of how
the solar wind acts on the earth whether
it's some other kind of particular
effect so first of all the model is
always some approximation that captures
certain features and discards other
features now you can ask the question so
just because this model this
mathematical model reproduces how the
earth goes around the Sun
then you say maybe can you conclude from
that that the earth is really operating
in a quotes mathematical kind of way
right well what would that mean I mean
it could mean that you would conclude
from that that inside the earth there
are lots of little Mathematica is
running that you know solve the
differential equations and compute where
the world tests you can send a rocket
and find the moon is right where you
expect it to be or whatever that I don't
know how you do right but but well you
test it in the same way that you would
test that but but just going back to
this issue about what it means to say
that the earth behaves in a mathematical
kind of way what it means is that this
abstract model that we have reproduces
what we observe that's that's the test
it's not in a sense that if you kind of
look inside that you'll see lots of
mathematics going on it's that this
abstract model reproduces what what it
is that we observe now in terms of can
we make predictions based on our model
absolutely you can make predictions
based on a model about celestial
mechanics for example yeah you can make
predictions based on the kinds of models
that I'm talking about here you could
say for example in the case of
snowflakes that oh let's say that big
snowflakes should have little holes in
them from where arms that have been
produced earlier in the growth of the
snowflake collided you go and check and
find out that that's actually true or
you could say they'll they'll be the the
distribution of shapes of leaves for
example will be this or that thing and
you can go and check I haven't actually
checked all of that to the logical
conclusion of this do you think that if
what we are seeing in these computer
programs is predictive of what really is
around us then do you think the that
that the entire universe may have flowed
out of say ten or four or one simple
rule yes I mean one of the things I
wouldn't have said that twenty years ago
for example before I had seen all the
things that I've now seen because I
would have said you know the universe
has just too much going on in it to be
able to be accounted for by some very
simple program very simple rule but
having seen the kinds of things I've
seen it sort of has led me to the the
intuitional result the
yes I think it is very plausible that
the whole universe and all the sort of
richness of what happens can be deduced
from some very simple underlying rule
how simple do you think so I would guess
that it'll be some rule that well let's
see if I can find an example here this
is weird I'm waiting to find out the
simple rule that creates the universe
well it doesn't often happen I waiting
for trains but not usually so these
aren't it ok I'm sorry to disappoint it
but these are perhaps a little bit like
it ok there may be a set of maybe four
or five of these rules and these rules
they're kind of abstract things they're
rules in this particular case that say
things about how the very underlying
pieces that make up space should get
updated over the course of time um and
my guess is that there's a a quite small
set of rules that if one were to run
them for long enough would reproduce
some precise detail everything that we
see in our universe now on the facing
don't you feel a little depressed at
that thought I mean if you had a
glorious being with a big long white
beard saying let there be light that has
a certain beauty to it yeah I know
you're a scientist but a lot of people I
think it's very beautiful or if you were
to just scoots really hard and build up
the whole universe from a set of rules
about gravity and you know ultimate
particles that has a certain tangible
you're suggesting that the whole thing
comes down to a little bit of computer
code I think that the if it was the case
that the whole universe could be the
result of something that one can sort of
some simple set of rules that one can
kind of hold in one's hand I think
that's one of the more beautiful
conclusions about how the universe works
at least to me it seems that way it's
sort of it's it's kind of something
where we're in a sense it's in part it's
sort of an ultimate triumph of of
thinking that it's possible to reduce
everything we see in our universe to
something that we can kind of hold in
our hand and talk about in an explicit
way do you think it's possible that you
will discover this rule
or will it be nor 10,000 years of
searching anything I don't think it'll
be 10,000 years of searching I mean it's
it's it requires I think that it's I've
managed to get a certain distance and
figuring out sort of what the rule might
look like and kind of develop in some of
the kind of technology that's needed to
actually do searches and things like
that
whether I certainly would find it a lot
of fun to find this rule but it's just
that I don't think you could build a
Sistine Chapel out of this kind of thing
but that's just maybe your prejudice
well if I'm right it was built that way
we should talk about modesty for a
second here in the book you describe
this theory as one of the more important
single discoveries in the whole history
of theoretical science you also say in
your preface I've discovered vastly more
than I ever thought possible in fact
what I've done now touches almost every
existing area of science and quite a bit
besides is it I wouldn't have read it
with quite that intonation
well I'm goofing on you but but the
question I guess is is there is normally
in scientists a adamant modesty I mean
they're like always so scared to declare
something's true because if anybody in
the universe finds out it doesn't isn't
quite true then they're wrong so it's
always so tentative you never seem to
break the pattern
depends on what scientists you talk to I
think they I think one finds all types
in science as one does in most other
places but but in the kinds of things
I've done one of the reasons that some
of what I've done doesn't have to be
quite as tentative is these these
systems you know when one looks at rule
30 or something like that
it does what it does it's not a
complicated experiment in a biology lab
where one can worry that once you know
Mouse have been unhappy that day and so
did the wrong thing it's something where
you run this this computer program and
the bits behave in the way that the bits
behave and you know you've got the right
answer there's no there's no kind of
issue of whether one's being modest or
not in saying that one has a word
it's just that's the way it is although
this idea of yours is very at this
moment anyway is got a lot of intuition
in it well the the the the core of what
I've tried to do is to sort of explore
what's out there in the computational
universe that is to sort of point
mathematica computer programs out into
sort of the computational universe and
see what kinds of things happen out in
the computational universe that that
kind of activity is one that's very kind
of definite and and and concrete and
hard and you know you look at a program
it does what it does now you can ask the
question so what does this mean why is
it interesting how does it apply to
other kinds of things and absolutely for
to come to conclusions on the basis of
that one has to have intuition whenever
one makes the model it's always
ultimately controversial because I can
say well I think the model captures the
important features of the phenomenon and
you can say well the future that's
important to me is a feature that you
didn't happen to capture in your model
so it sort of depends how are you going
to use the model what do you think is
important whether you know kind of
whether we'll agree about whether this
model is really the right model although
you also said in one of those notes and
the notes by the way are pretty
fascinating in their almost level almost
poetry and there's one called clarity
and modesty it's in the back and
essentially what it says is I gotta like
sing it out loud so people can't get the
majesty of it otherwise if I were to
sing it tepidly they might mistake this
for something like minor key well I've
been lucky enough that I don't operate
you know i-i've as you mentioned I can
sort of be an independent scientist I'm
not sort of subject to the the detailed
practices of kind of the the Society of
scientists and so on although I have a
great many friends and the sort of kind
of Society of scientists but it's it's
something where one thing that one
realizes is it's hard to communicate big
ideas I mean I tried communicating some
of the ideas that are now in the book in
the form of kind of more traditional
scientific papers I mentioned and it
didn't really wasn't really something
that could get across that way and one
of the things that I think one has to
realize is that that
when one tries to explain an idea if I
say okay there's this thing that's
called rule 30 and it kind of has this
thing that isn't quite a fractal and it
doesn't quite have you know
renormalization group properties and it
doesn't quite have this and you know
kind of all you know it doesn't seem
like this is something that's really
important and this is something that's
actually at the core of understanding
how complexity happens in nature it's
kind of unfair to people to just sort of
present it as this is a long series of
technical properties and so on right I
think that in a sense one one in writing
scientific papers for example there are
certain conventions that are followed
for example in mathematics papers people
will say at the beginning of a
mathematics paper it will say something
like you know let F be a field now we
will prove the following properties the
end of the paper it says you know QED we
prove what we wanted
it will nowhere say why one was ever
going to why one was interested in doing
this it will just be a very formal
presentation of what's true in other
areas of science there's a little bit
more description that's conventional
about kind of why we're doing what we're
doing
one of the tracks that's often lost in
traditional scientific discourse is how
important does one think it is because
often the person who spent the 20 years
or whatever working on something they
have some reasonable idea whether it's
important or not or maybe you know just
identity perhaps so let me I mean
because I and we're gonna run out a I'm
gonna let me just run through a couple
of my confusions one of them is why you
like pineapple juice and 7up but I won't
quit it yet still your favorite soft
thing so far yes changes gradually I
want to understand this idea that
everything about us is a computation
which so if I see a rain cloud
there's input and output how would you
how could you describe to me a rain
cloud as a computation or my shoe as a
computation well so normally when we
talk about computations we think of them
as sort of processes something the rain
the you know the the the the air has
some sort of distribution of humidity
and temperature and
this sort of thing and over the course
of time that distribution of humidity
and temperature and so on will cause
there to be some condensed rain cloud
there and then over the course of time
other things will happen maybe it will
produce rain things like this but you're
looking at the cloud and thinking ticka
ticka ticka ticka ticka so you're
generating millions and millions of
clouds one right after the other and
they're doing something like the
cellular automata did yes so they're
going input input boom boom rule rain
yes but not my shoe I don't know so much
about that I haven't thought much about
shoes shoe just sits there so I'm trying
it's a little hard for me to think like
so so you don't let that shoe in there
do you
let's see what I have there I mean this
takes a little getting used to this idea
if we look at so these are these are
some of the simplest cellular automata
okay so there's some of them that do
really pretty boring things they in a
sense just sit there
so in this at least at this level of
modeling that's like your shoe
I think whereas other ones do much more
elaborate things that are much more like
the kind of elaborate patterns of
turbulence and so on that one sees in in
flow around clouds and things like that
see I have a couple of objections that I
recorded as I was reading long one of
them we've already gone through Ray
Kurzweil wrote about an eight thousand
word jeremiad in which he says you know
I'm looking at this he says and I think
that while they can evolve into
interesting shapes and even shapes that
remind me of things in the real world is
one could run these automata for
trillions even trillions and trillions
of iterations they do not evolve and to
say insects or humans or Chopin preludes
or anything else that has a really
higher level of complexity or how would
you answer a ray cause one so one of the
things one has to do is one has to get
intuition about what what is possible to
have happen and sort of absent the
computer experiments that I did my
intuition would have been with rules
this simple you'll never get a nothing
terribly complicated
and that's the intuition and I think Rea
probably has that same intuition that is
there's no there's no way to imagine
that with rules as simple as the kinds
of things I'm talking about one can get
these very elaborate things happening
and it's not surprising one doesn't have
that intuition it's you know that's
that's the thing one discovers from
doing lots of computer experiments and
that's an intuition that I've tried to
develop from doing those computer
experiments but you can only really get
it by looking at what happens in those
those computer experiments you're saying
based on four years of being in the
Attic and working it and working it and
working it and working it my gut tells
me that I can birth a real human being
out of this stuff and Rea you should
just come up to the attic and spend some
time with me sort of right well I think
I think one of the things that's that
Rea cuts well in particular has thought
a bunch about is the question of for
example will we be able to make machines
that think right okay and so he spent a
lot of time trying to convince people
that it really is going to be possible
to make machines that think now in fact
what I've done and what he finds kind of
scary is to go much beyond that you sure
if my shoes are computation and I'm a
computation and this glass has a
computation you know if we're all kind
of complex the shoe the glass at me then
any one of us could think it just
happens to be odd that I'm thinkers I
think I'm thinking but right but in your
lights everything could think right well
so one of the questions is is there sort
of an abstract distinction between the
kind of computation that happens in the
case of for example human intelligence
and the kind of computation that happens
and let's say a turbulent fluid right
and I certainly would have had the
intuition before I looked at the things
that I looked at that there would be
some sort of fundamental difference what
I have now concluded from the things
that I've looked at is that there really
isn't that it's really there's a sort of
fundamental equivalence at least at the
level of sort of the sophistication of
computations that can happen between
what happens in let's say turbulent
fluid flow and what can happen in
something like a brain and that's in a
sense
so that's isn't that body if I say this
equals your brain
seems like someone's suffering in the
comparison well so one of the things is
that this whole phenomenon of kind of
went when we look at something like like
that that complicated cyllid automaton
that rule 30 cellular automaton thing
when we look at this we can ask the
question why does this look complex to
us what what's the sort of fundamental
reason well I think it has to do with
this comparison between our brains and
things like splashes of water and things
like the rule 30 cellular automata
because what we're kind of used to I
mean science one of the kind of basic
idealizations and traditional science
tends to be the observer is kind of
infinitely computationally powerful
relative to the systems that they're
observing I mean it's been one of the
trends in science that we've gotten more
and more realistic about what we as
observers can actually do that was sort
of a fundamental thing about studying
quantum theory in other kinds of things
well what happens here is that one's
getting sort of realistic about the
computational abilities of the observer
if the observer is sort of infinitely
computationally powerful relative to
something like one of these simple
abstract cellular automata then the
observer can decode what it's doing then
it may be going and sort of updating
every cell in some way that it thinks is
very elaborate but we as kind of
infinitely computationally powerful
things can always decode what it was
doing right and can say well even though
it may have taken you a million steps to
do this I can work out immediately what
you'll have what will have happened
after million steps what what I'm saying
here is that that in fact there's that
that isn't really right that we're not
really infinitely computationally
powerful relative to systems like this
in fact we're computationally equivalent
to systems like this so that means that
the computation that we can do to
predict these systems are no more
sophisticated than the computations that
these systems in effect do themselves to
work out what they're going to do well
in plain English that means that if I'm
really trying to figure out how a cloud
works or how cornflakes pour out of a
cornflake box that may be too
complicated for me to get and I may not
ever be able to predict well but so
doesn't that mean you've taken science
which has always had as its greatest
power the power to predict if I shoot
the can
all up in the air thumb thumb thumb
thumb thumb I know where it's going to
land but in your science because
everything is but many things are very
complicated equally complicated nobody
can figure out what everybody's doing
because everybody's equally mystified
that seems a little weak for so it isn't
in a sense what what this so it kind of
goes in two directions one thing is it's
pretty useful to know what the sort of
ultimate limitations of one's
methodology or once science are going to
be it would be unfortunate if we kind of
went along thinking we'll be able to
write down a mathematical equation for
everything which is kind of a idea that
one might have had from from sort of
early progress of physics and things
like that if in fact there's some
fundamental obstruction there's some
fundamental reason why one can never do
that it's useful to know that and in
fact one can make predictions even from
just knowing that one can't write down a
formula one can make predictions about
how this so that thing must seem random
because they can't be a formula that can
be written down for it things like that
but what what will happens is that what
you see is that there's there's a
certain sort of ultimate computational
irreducibility
to phenomena there's sort of a an
ultimate point beyond which you can't
compress what's going to happen beyond
which you can't make predictions about
what will happen sort of faster than the
system itself does its thing but in a
sense there's an awful lot of science
that can be done in these kind of
pockets of reducibility
that for various lot of science that
probably can't be done because we're not
able to compute faster than yes even a
rock maybe if there's a really smart
rock 11 well so and that that has things
to say about all sorts of questions like
for example questions about determinism
versus freewill for instance um this
sort of a mystery about you know if we
follow definite rules why is it that we
seem to be acting in a way that's free
of definite rules and a way that's very
hard to predict
well this phenomenon of computational
reducibility gives us kind of a
scientific basis for that kind of
everyday phenomenon that we observe I
mean someone's a computer is running
through me and I all my actions are
determined by the
simple rule in the machine from the
other universe wherever it is but I
can't know it because it's so
complicated I can't read it so I'm both
predetermined and I have no idea what
the what the future is because I can't
guess well I should read some questions
because other people want to get out of
here probably so so um here are some
questions I have spent the better part
of my adult life studying evolution have
I been wasting my time no of course not
I mean the the you know a thing to say
about the science that I've tried to do
you know existing science has been
immensely successful it's sort of one of
the greatest sort of intellectual
successes in the history of civilization
and and there's there's there there are
there many areas many achievements that
have come from that and is not my goal
to kind of say no no that was all a
waste of time
one should be doing something different
instead my goal has been to say there's
something else one can also look at and
that one can see by looking sort of out
there in the computational world seeing
what programs do those sorts of things
and a way that one can address questions
that traditional science has not been
very successful at addressing and for
example in the area of evolution there's
sort of been this this question of so
how is it that really complicated stuff
gets to happen in biology and it's kind
of seemed unintuitive to people that
sort of things like evolution can
actually lead to complicated stuff
happening I think that's that's sort of
in a sense the core of why so many
people kind of think that there must be
something going on beyond just these
sort of simple steps of evolution in a
sense what I've tried to do is to
explain that there is a definite
mechanism by which simple programs that
could be perhaps picked at random in the
genetic code of an organism can actually
lead to complicated things happen so
you'd say maybe there are six kinds of
birch trees that are possible or twelve
kinds of mollusks and then each mollusk
can take his or her choice about what
kind of mollusk they want to be within
the frame and then the ones that serve
the ones that are survived you know are
fittest in their environment will be the
ones that so you know you know lemon
darwinian no no no but the issue is if
you want to explain how do you get an
incredibly intricate pattern on a shell
then one possible explanation would be
one gets this pattern because that
pattern is optimal according to some
elaborate sort of criterion of
optimality from the computer no no that
from-from sort of thinking in kind of
traditional emotional biology kind of
thought okay and often realistically one
has to go to a lot of trouble to in a
sense make up something that the thing
one sees could be optimal for what I'm
saying is when one sees something
complicated going on it won't
necessarily that it isn't right to
explain it as its optimal for some very
complicated thing often what will have
happened is that a quite simple program
will have been picked at random and so
long as that program wasn't disastrous
for the organism that'll be what the
organism will have ended up using and
it's sort of just because of this
abstract fact that simple programs can
produce very complicated behavior that
we can see very complicated things
happening in these biological systems I
wonder if they're biologists in the room
they might you know particularly
cellular biologist they may be good but
we'll look we'll see do you ever have
regrets about walking away from particle
physics and isn't the reason not much is
happening in this field is that your
absent from it sorry mom do I say
something about that I mean I I think
that that it's been sort of interesting
for me because I have been you know I
did particle physics 20 something 23
years ago and and more and it's been
it's been strange because I have now you
know I had thought well it would be very
nice to be able to come up with a more
fundamental theory of physics at the
time but I didn't see any way to do it
though I started looking at these other
kinds of issues that seemed like why
would they lead to anything that had
anything to do with fundamental physics
they were things about you know
snowflake growth from biology and things
like that what has been interesting and
frankly somewhat surprising to me is
that the kinds of fundamental ideas that
I've looked at from sort of looking at
simple programs and so on do now give me
some insight I think into how
fundamental
it's works and it's sort of a thing that
in a sense is not uncommon that the best
way to make progress on the thing you
first thought you should be working on
you look at this trick just to go and do
something else first the answer is right
here everywhere you haven't left
anything behind you've embraced but
you've said it's taken you ten years to
internalize your new science please
explain or define internalization that's
interesting okay so I mean that I would
say that the point is does one have a
good intuition about what will happen so
for example a test for me is I have some
computer experiment I'm going to do it
can I guess what kind of result this
computer experiment will give or not hmm
so for instance here's a funny example
of a prediction you asked about
predictions earlier normally one thinks
about predictions as being relevant in
things like Natural Science in in a
field like mathematics it's not sort of
defined or judged on the basis of making
predictions within itself it's judged on
whether sort of this this corpus of
mathematical knowledge will end up being
useful well in the kinds of things I've
done one of the strange things that
happens is one sort of has an
experimental version of mathematics in
which there can actually be predictions
and so for example from the things I
done I had various predictions about how
certain simple cellular automata would
be capable of so-called Universal
computation about how the axioms for
logic how one could have very simple
axioms for logic and sort of the test of
whether I'd kind of successfully
internalized successfully developed the
right intuition was did I make the right
prediction about whether in fact the
cellular automata will be computation
universal about whether there would be
some very simple axiom for logic and
some give this intuition kick in as you
wrote the formula or as it unfolded line
26 line 3008 it's like a roulette wheel
I mean you know oh I think it's gonna go
to 36 flat but you know I don't know
well it's more when one tries to for
example search for a simple axiom for
logic for instance that's a technically
comparatively complicated thing to do
the question is does one have the
intuition to imagine that it will be
worth trying to do and that was that
that was the kind of thing
deep down is randomness deterministic is
the world digital and discrete in its
foundations those are two different
questions deep down is randomness
deterministic that's interesting
well so one is dangerous yes they are
the UM when one sees phenomena that
appear random I think they're really
three kinds of explanations that one can
have for those sorts of phenomena so the
first X first kind of explanation is one
that's been kind of the the most common
one and traditional science which is
randomness somehow comes from
perturbations from the environment so
sort of an example of that would be lets
say a boat bobbing on an ocean you know
the boat itself doesn't produce any
randomness but there's this ocean that
kind of has random waves on it and that
makes the boat move in a in a seemingly
random way so sort of explanation number
one that works for things like boats
bobbing on an ocean or Brownian motion
or thermal noise electronic noise these
kinds of things is the randomness comes
from something in the environment that's
random that's kind of kicking the system
one's looking at explanation number two
was kind of the chaos theory explanation
which was there's no randomness that's
continually injected into a system
that's continually kicking the system
instead the randomness comes because
there's some detail of the initial
conditions of the system that we didn't
know so for example if you let's say if
you take a roulette wheel as an example
the once once the roulette wheel is
started there's no randomness in how it
moves but the reason you can't predict
what will happen in the end is that
where the ball will eventually land
depends very sensitively on what the
precise speed at which the the the wheel
and so on was started was and if it was
done for example by hand there's there's
some sort of that there's some you don't
know that it's random it's it's some and
that's a that's why right yeah right and
so so the sort of chaos theory
explanation says you get randomness out
because you you because the details of
the initial conditions for the system
are not known and so as you as the
system sort of does its thing it
gradually excavates more and more detail
from the initial conditions and because
those weren't known what comes out is
unpredictable but that explanation is in
a sense again an explanation that says
there's really no way the system itself
makes randomness it's just somehow
there's randomness that was injected
from the outside in this case in the
initial conditions so one question is is
there really any randomness that can
actually be made in systems that we look
at or is sort of all the randomness that
we see kind of randomness that comes
from outside what we're looking at that
would be kind of a cop-out explanation
that ultimately couldn't work because
we'd always be kind of passing the buck
about where the randomness came from so
so well it so happens the very picture
that I that I have up here of a rule 30
is an illustration of how things can be
different so what happens in rule 30 is
you start off from just one black cell
of the beginning there's sort of no
randomness in that you have a very
definite rule that there's no sort of
randomness in the rule yet the patterns
that you get out have many aspects of
randomness in fact they're good enough
at emulating randomness that for example
the random sequence generator in
Mathematica for the past 15 years has
been based on rule 30 and works really
well randomness then for is an extra
ingredient I mean it kicks in well know
what what's happening is ones
intrinsically generating randomness this
is a system that in it's very intrinsic
nature it generates randomness so the
question I know I guess a we should you
should go on here so they didn't want to
have how have your ideas and processes
been applied to financial markets so
well I've tried to make some
applications of what I've done to
financial markets I there's been
considerable interest in in doing that
based on the kinds of things that are in
my book one of the questions about a
financial market is sort of one of the
most obvious phenomena in financial
markets is that the the prices of things
tend to fluctuate roughly randomly and
the question is where does that
randomness come from and so these
explanations of randomness that I just
gave a kind of kind of relevance yeah
one explanation could be the randomness
in the market comes from kind of the
environment outside kind of kicking the
the the traders and causing this price
to fluctuate randomly but another
possible explanation is that the
randomness is somehow intrinsic to the
dynamics of the market itself so that if
for example you had sort of program
trading systems that had definite
algorithms but they were trading
each other it could still be the case
that even though their algorithms were
sort of completely definite and so on
that there could still be randomness
that was observed in the in the time
series of prices in the market I've
looked a little bit at the question of
which of these two sources of randomness
is the most important one in markets I
think the main thing I discovered is
that it's it's some it's complicated to
you know it's difficult to decode the
data in that in that situation it's more
difficult than in places like physics
and biology and so on because there
there are many more detailed things that
go on in that data and so I haven't come
to a conclusion but so many traders and
so little time of the scientists and
philosophers of science who do you
admire the most you're not allowed to
admire yourself I don't think I wouldn't
okay well gee I mean I think the the the
usual suspects probably among scientists
I mean you know I'm quite a serious
student of the history of science and I
kind of have this this this idea that
sort of by studying the history of
various areas of science and the people
who did it that one can help to kind of
predict and shape what one does oneself
in in a more effective way but I think
um I think the the folks that I would
consider to be admirable scientists
probably pretty much the same as as the
usual list from you know Newton Darwin
Turing girdle you know the usual
suspects Alan Turing gets an awful lot
of mention in this book
he's probably your most oft mentioned
guy he is yes Mike I think probably if
he had lived longer than he did he might
very well have discovered many of the
things that I discovered but more than
John man women who I was I would have
put a bet and he would have gotten more
mentions but Turing yes oh yeah how do
you respond to critics who assert that
cellular automata is just a new
computational method not the new science
well cellular automata as such I would
tend to agree what the the new science
that I'm trying to define is really the
science that you've got
by kind of looking out in the
computational world and seeing what's
there that that's which is kind of a
thing you know in in biology one sort of
looks out in the in the in the world of
biological organisms and things or
biological processes and sees what's
there that's you know what I'm trying to
do is to sort of look out in the world
of computational processes and see
what's there and and that's the kind of
science that I'm trying to define here's
my last question but they're less
efficient if you are in a conversation
with Einstein Einstein Bohr Heisenberg
Gelman Fineman Feynman and other
prominent thinkers what would you expect
to be the most compelling challenge to
your theory this is a good question well
the first one of the first challenges
would be can you explain quantum
mechanics that will be one of the first
things that would come up I think that
is from me can this explain what we get
yes yes I think that the kind of idea of
a model of physics that's based on very
definite kind of deterministic rules
it's kind of long been thought that that
kind of blows you out of being able to
explain quantum mechanics because
quantum mechanics has sort of
fundamental probabilistic kinds of
things in it I have a guess about how
that will work out and about how things
like this so-called violation of bells
inequalities is some is a is something
which is sort of an essential apparently
a central feature of quantum mechanics
that seems hard to get in the
deterministic system I kind of have a
guess about how that will emerge through
essentially the fact that space is not
as simple a construct as we have
normally thought that it was and when
one sort of gets more realistic about
what space says I think that this
questions about sort of how one can get
quantum mechanics and violation of bells
and equalities and so on will kind of
emerge from that but I don't know
exactly how that works and that would be
I would guess the the most immediate
challenge the first challenge a
challenge that might come would be how
do you explain draw general
the theory of gravity that one I think I
know how to do so that one I that one i
can that one I could get likewise
special relativity but but quantum
mechanics I have some guesses about how
that will work but um that would be a
fascinating discussion well thank you
for this fascinating discussion thank
you all